your men yeah
I mean
yeah I look like huh
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana
I do not deserve you if you never met a
man before but what about your father I
had no father I was brought to life by
Zeus bollocks need
I cannot do this
what I do is none up to you
it's at a candy I'm at Steve Trevor's
secretary what is the secretary I go
where he tells me to go when I do what
he tells me to do I'm where I'm from
that's called slavery I really like her
fantastic ladies after you into how you
like
happy comic-con day 3 they dropped the
actual Wonder Woman trailer so let's
break it down there's a whole bunch of
other DC stuff too so I'll explain at
the end of this so some of the stuff you
probably know about the film like you
know Chris Pine is playing Steve Trevor
it's a pretty straight up telling of her
origin story from the comics and uh
they're like a couple of different
origin stories for a Wonder Woman but
she kind of acknowledges it with a wing
just saying zeus created me she's the
daughter of Hippolyta and Zeus and if
you couldn't tell from the trailer this
is set during World War 1 era so like
the main villain Jack Houston here he's
not a Nazi like the Nazi Party didn't
rise till World War two I just I so love
that she looks like she's going ready to
assassinate him with her sword in the
back of her dress but just the way she
moves in this trailer in the soundtrack
was so amazing it was one of the best
parts of Batman V Superman whenever she
entered the film she had her own special
music it's straight out of that and just
look at the color like this is just so
fantastically beautiful the poster they
released a couple days ago is actually a
pretty good example of how colorful the
movie is like it's just so eye-popping
and even when you see her step onto the
battlefield like she's on the front line
in the actual trenches stepping up and
even though she's covered in dirt like
everything scuffed the classic Justice
League colors against this brown dirt
just looks so great and what am I
actually one of my favorite shots though
is from earlier in the trailer when
Steve Trevor washes up like the way they
opened the trailer with her face just
against the sky just looking so
beautiful you've had this accident you
wash up on this short you think you're
dead and all you can see as you stare up
into this guy is the face of this
goddess so you're like oh she is way too
beautiful
I am definitely dead and I do appreciate
some of the gender humor in this what do
I do I not look like a man Oh in my
world we call that slavery we get a
better look at the mascara this is
actually good test for Atlantis like
Atlantis is going to look like this
really otherworldly place and I know
that doesn't appear in this trailer but
they had like all the DC directors for
all the different films they even
brought Affleck onstage at the panel
because he's directing the Batman film
that James Wan who's a horror director
was talking about Aquaman and Alana's
about how she's going to be so
terrifying in so beautiful at the same
time which is kind of what's going on in
this trailer like all these goddesses
look so amazingly beautiful but they're
just terrifying warriors and then you
see all these German troops come to
Thema secure so the way they explained
some of the backstory for the Amazon
it fits into the context of the DC movie
universe their initial role in society
was to protect mankind but they've since
kind of bailed on the task just because
as you can see with the situation in
World War one Humanity is ready to
destroy itself
so they've almost given up Wonder Woman
is the one who answers the call like
she's inspired by a Steve Trevor
wants to help them out so she reenters
the world like Hippolyta is like you're
my greatest treasure be careful
so Wonder Woman's trying to inspire and
save humanity but as you can see the
teaser is is that even though the
Amazons have tried to retreat from
society the war comes to them so we will
get to see the Amazons just absolutely
throw down I cannot wait to see Robin
Wright Penn who most of you probably
only know from house of cards recently
just go apeshit on everyone even
Hippolyta is like this really fearsome
warrior they're all very powerful so get
hype for Amazon's wrecking the [ __ ] out
of all of these German troops just look
at the way she moves through some of
these scenes too at this fight scene
where she busts in with all these
Germans and just goes crazy like you saw
her move really fast during Batman V
Superman during the doomsday fight but
this gives you a much better sense of
her abilities I'm hoping they actually
released the soundtrack before the movie
comes out but if you guys did know this
is coming out summer of next year so
it's going to be a little while before
it's released and they even drop the
Justice League teaser trailer so that's
gonna be my next video that should post
in like the next hour too so just really
happy with the DC panel in general just
really awesome so happy they've brought
out all of these directors but there's
going to be a whole bunch more footage
coming tonight from all the Marvel in
the DC stuff so be sure to subscribe to
get all that and because there's so much
DC stuff I'm just going to name a new
winner right now so congratulations to
Justin Portillo you win a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
there's a new round starting now I'll
just announce the winner when I post my
flash trailer video later tonight so
they'll be like a whole bunch of
giveaways happening this weekend between
Marvel and DC stuff so get I lots more
stuff coming today while you guys wait
for that Justice League video to post
you can click here for my breakdown of
the Game of Thrones Season 7 teaser and
you can click here for all my other
Comic Con videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight